now companies are using blackmail to
bully you into tipping and they're
demanding the tip before the service is
rendered and we'll get back to that in a
second NBC had a report on this new
system from door Dash which is which
it's rolling out as a trial balloon to
see just how much customers hate it and
customers will hate it and they'll do it
anyway NBC spoke to a door Dash driver
who uh made his case for why we should
tip him here's what he said it hurts
your
feelings it hurts your feelings more
when they tip you a penny the food
delivery service added this pop of
disclaimer as part of a pilot program
it's 5
miles
and maybe there's a dollar tip maybe but
it's just
like I don't know are you going to take
that order no I'm not going to take that
definitely not it hurts his feelings
when you don't tip so make sure you tip
or the man on the bicycle might start
crying B